[Musique]
avis favorable du conseil d'état
concernant le projet de loi sur les
nouvelles mesures anti-copie 19 après
son examen aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres le texte arrivera demain à
l'assemblée nationale puis au sénat
l jeudi une extension du pass sanitaires
et la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants au centre des débats
objectif pour l'exécutif éviter de
perdre le contrôle fasse son rebond
d'épidémie
liberté retrouvée pour l'angleterre la
quasi-totalité des restrictions
sanitaires a pris fin à ce lundi
l'obligation du port du masque dans les
magasins et des transports la fin des
jauges en intérieur également à des
mesures prises alors que le royaume uni
fait face à une forte hausse du nombre
de contaminations la barre des 50 mille
cas quotidiens et les hospitalisations
sont en progression malgré un taux de
vaccination élevé
[Musique]
en afrique du sud de reprise du procès
de l'ex président jacob zuma sous haute
sécurité
une audience sous forme virtuelle afin
d'éviter d'attiser de nouvelles
violences après une semaine à d'émeutes
qui ont ébranlé le pays
plus de 200 personnes ont été tuées la
cause homo doit répondre de six chefs
d'accusation de fraude corruption et
raquettes
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à vous si
vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
semaine décisive pour le projet de loi
sur l'extension du pass sanitaire validé
sous conditions par le conseil d'état la
dernière version du texte arrivera en
commission à l'assemblée nationale dès
demain les députés examineront le texte
et auditionneront les ministres avant un
débat qui s'annonce houleux dans
l'hémicycle en cause des mesures jugées
liberticides par certains les précisions
de notre reporter guilmard aussi bonsoir
guilmain gabriela talent a dévoilé la
dernière version de ce projet de loi en
sait-on plus sur ce texte qui sera on
sert largement débattue elle durant les
prochains jours au sein de l'hémicycle
[Musique]
eh bien oui david doit écouter il y a
tout d'abord ce qui ne change pas c'est
à dire l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants 15 septembre ou encore
l'extension des restrictions au barreau
gare ou encore au restaurant et puis il
y a ceux qui a d'ores et déjà été
modifié dans ce texte notamment les
sanctions
on ne parle plus par exemple de la deûle
amende de 45000 euros pour les
établissements qui ne contrôleraient pas
le pasteur ni terme et seulement 2000
euros pour une première infraction à
noter également david que le conseil
d'état vient de retoquer l'obligation de
contrôle du pass sanitaires pour les
grands centres commerciaux la haute
juridiction administrative qui a en
revanche validé l'obligation d'isolement
de dix jours pour les personnes
positives au covin 19
alors ce texte il doit être désormais
adoptée par le parlement c'est une
procédure éclair qui va s'engager demain
à l'assemblée nationale le texte sera
adopté sont quelques jours une semaine
tout au plus et donc devrait entrer en
vigueur au début du mois d'août sauf et
sauf si le conseil constitutionnel est
saisi comme ont prévu de le faire déjà
plusieurs groupes parlementaires et dans
ces cas vu
aider les biens de ce fameux pass
sanitaires pour une entrée en
application le cas la fin de l'été merci
beaucoup il marre aussi en direct depuis
l'elysée
des mesures sanitaires qui vont avoir
des conséquences forcément sur le
commerce une nouvelle fois pour les
hôtels notamment la situation des
hôteliers parisiens sont dans
l'incertitude 70% des hôtels parisiens
indépendants pourraient fermer en août
écoutez à ce propos geneviève à leur
directrice de l'hôtel quatre étoiles
littré à paris le mois de juillet au
mois d'août à paris sont généralement
des mois très très calme
sauf que la clientèle internationale est
totalement absente cette année comme
l'année dernière d'ailleurs donc
généralement ce sont les américains les
brésiliens des canadiens l'aérien
n'étant pas du tout reparti c'est une
une clientèle qui nous fait défaut et
finalement le panther vous avez 2 %
entre 2 et 5 % de taux d'occupation
la question de ce beau sport il faut
mieux rester fermés que d'ouvrir un
hôtel avec aucune clientèle possible
et alors qu'en france on se prépare à
montrer patte blanche à l'entrée d'un
grand nombre de lieux publics en russie
la mesure a été levée dans la capitale
les moscovites n'ont plus à présenter de
qr code pour accéder au restaurant bar
club ou discothèques
on voit ça avec verhaeghe hoffman notre
correspondante à moscou le code cup ni
plus moscou élèves l'obligation de
présenter un certificat numérique à
l'entrée des restaurants et cafés
les autorités de la capitale explique
cette décision par la baisse du nombre
des hospitalisations ainsi que
l'augmentation radicale du nombre des
personnes vaccinées tout en
reconnaissant que la situation à moscou
reste compliqué je vous propose
d'écouter la situation à moscou demeure
compliquée néanmoins nous enregistrons
une amélioration des principaux
indicateurs depuis quatre semaines déjà
en comparaison avec le pic épidémique
le nombre de cas de covin 19 détectés
chaque jour à pratiquement 10 min
moitié le nombre d'hospitalisations a
diminué d'un tiers
bien entendu cela a été rendu possible
grâce aux restrictions sanitaires
imposées ainsi qu'au renforcement des
mesures sanitaires et comme vous l'avez
fait remarquer à juste titre grâce à la
vaccination de masse le crâne en
soutient la décision des autorités
moscovites selon dmitri peskov le porte
parole du président russe moscou a déjà
prouvé son efficacité dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie écouter les autorités
moscovites ont prouvé à plusieurs
reprises leur efficacité dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus le système de
soins de santé à moscou assez de
potentiel pour augmenter rapidement le
nombre de lits dans les hôpitaux pour
intégrer rapidement des réserves
je dirais que dans le cadre de la mise
en oeuvre de ces pouvoirs spéciaux des
autorités de moscou prenne cette
décision et je le répète encore une fois
moscou a déjà prouvé son efficacité et a
fait ses preuves dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie
les contaminations sont effectivement
baisse plus de vingt quatre mille
nouveaux cas de coronavirus ont été
détectés en russie ces dernières 24
heures dont près de 4000 à moscou
le nombre des blessés est descendu à 719
jours de liberté l'angleterre l'ale ces
dernières mesures sanitaires aujourd'hui
un pari risqué pour le gouvernement
russe britannique au vu de la hausse des
cas de contamination due aux variants
delta lé masque n'est plus obligatoire
dans les transports et les lieux publics
à l'ouverture des discothèques jose
plein pour les salles de spectacles
cinéma bien encore les stades
le point avec camille la bnda le ruban
est coupé après 17 mois de fermeture
la fête peut désormais reprendre dans
cette boîte de nuit londonienne fini les
masques les règles de distanciation
sociale et les limites à la
fréquentation des théâtres des grands
événements c'est une occasion très
joyeuse et j'aime danser et tout mon
cercle d'amis aime danser et nous
n'avons pas pu le faire depuis un an et
demi environ donc nous sommes vraiment
excités à ce sujet ce masque ne le
montre pas mais il ya un petit sourire
en dessous
une levée des dernières restrictions
sanitaires jugé nécessaire par le
premier ministre britannique
c'est donc le bon moment mais nous
devons agir avec prudence
nous devons nous rendre compte que ce
virus est toujours là que le nombre de
cas augmente nous pouvons constater
l'extrême contagiosité du variant delta
mais nous avons cette immense
consolation et cette satisfaction de
savoir qu il ne fait aucun doute que le
programme de vaccination a gravement
affaibli le lien entre maladie
hospitalisations et décès et c'est ce
qui est primordial
ironie du sort à la veille de ce freedom
day pour jour de la liberté
boris johnson déclaré qu'à contacter le
18 juillet devra s'isoler quand il ne
travaille pas de quoi laisser des
britanniques perplexe pour les
scientifiques
cette levée des dernières contraintes
sanitaires est qualifiée de dangereuse
et inadapté vu la situation du pays
ce n'était pas le bon moment pour lever
complètement toutes les restrictions
alors que les niveaux d'infections et
d'hospitalisation augmente et même si la
vaccination a considérablement affaibli
le lien entre les infections les
hospitalisations et les décès
nous sommes toujours dans une position
très difficile ici en angleterre et je
pense que ce n'est pas le bon moment
pour lever toutes les restrictions dans
un communiqué mille deux cents
scientifiques internationaux critiquent
la décision de boris johnson
il assure que son plan pourrait
entraîner un à deux millions de
contaminations ces prochaines semaines
et potentiellement plus de cent mille
nouveaux cas de co vide par jour au
cours de l'été des estimations qui
risque d'aggraver un bilan déjà
dramatique avec plus de 128 mille morts
le royaume uni reste le pays le plus
meurtrier en europe par le coronavirus
la stratégie de boris johnson pourrait
s'avérer gagnante en particulier auprès
des jeunes anglais c'est en tout cas
l'avis de paul thompson vice-président
du parti conservateur britannique en
france le fait que des jeunes peuvent se
croiser dans des matchs de football des
boîtes nuit et cetera d'une certaine
manière peut avoir du bon par rapport au
combat générale contre le virus parce
que les jeunes peuvent s'infecter
mutuellement et donc là la part de la
population qui d'ici la rentrée aura été
immunisés soit pour de vaccination soit
du fait d'avoir été infectées sans que
cela donne lieu à des mêmes des
symptômes c'est cette combinaison de ces
deux un fait peu et seul espoir de les
autorités je crois dans des lieux à un
niveau très élevé de la progression qui
est immunisée ailleurs dans le monde la
répercussion directe du commis 19
continue d'impacter les autres pays par
exemple pour le grand pèlerinage de la
mecque qu'il a commencé samedi et pour
la deuxième année consécutive ils se
déroulent dans un cadre sanitaires très
strictes
seul un nombre limité de fidèles
musulmans et résidents d'arabie saoudite
ont été autorisés à se rendre dans la
ville sainte fare amis qu ils étaient
plus de 2 millions à avoir fait le
déplacement en 2010
cette année seuls 60 mille croyants sont
autorisés à accomplir l'un des cinq
piliers de l'islam
en raison de la pandémie de kobe de 19
le piège ou grand pèlerinage se fait en
petit comité à la mecque
seule condition pour réaliser les
différents rites être résidents du
royaume d'arabie saoudite
avoir entre 18 et 65 ans et surtout être
vacciné il grâce à dieu nous avons
obtenu l'autorisation d'effectuer le
hajj même si on ne s'attendait pas à
être acceptés en raison du nombre limité
de pèlerins a accepté et comme vous
pouvez le constater le gouvernement
saoudien fait de son mieux
tout est bien organisé cette année les
autorités saoudiennes n'ont pas lésiné
sur les mesures sanitaires de nombreux
agents d'entretien ont été déployés dans
les différents lieux saints près de 1500
litres de produits désinfectants sont
utilisées quotidiennement pour nettoyer
le sol
autre nouveauté des robots sont utilisés
pour vaporiser du désinfectant
je travaille ici à la grande mosquée
depuis 15 ans aujourd'hui nous nettoyons
ce site avec trois équipes de nettoyage
qui effectue une rotation
nous nettoyons le sol dix fois avec des
désinfectants à cause du gros navires us
depuis le début de la pandémie
l'arabie saoudite a répertorié plus de
quatre cent soixante deux mille cas de
corona virus et 8000 décès le royaume
wahhabite a alors fermé ses frontières
et suspendu les entrées de pèlerins sur
son sol une industrie qui est la
deuxième source de revenus du pays après
le pétrole lui rapportant de 10 à 15
milliards d'euros chaque année
aux etats unis la maison blanche indique
faire de la lutte contre la
désinformation autour de la vaccination
contre le coc vide une de ses priorités
pour en parler on retrouve tout de suite
notre correspondant à washington aux
abonnés
l'abonné bonsoir l'administration weiden
hausse le ton contre les plateformes
numériques dans quel but
et bien cela fait plusieurs mois que joe
biden tente de convaincre toujours plus
d'américains de se faire vacciner
beaucoup d'efforts sont déployés par
l'administration de la maison blanche et
la semaine dernière il y avait donc une
conférence de presse à la maison blanche
conférence de presse pour aborder ce
sujet de la lutte contre la
désinformation notamment la
désinformation en ligne selon elle est
donnée de la maison blanche 67% des
américains non vaccinés ont été exposés
au moins une fois à une fausse
information et quelques instants plus
tard joe biden a été interrogé justement
sur le rôle de ces plateformes
numériques dans cette lutte contre la
désinformation écoutez sa réponse et
surtout ces accusations très virulente à
l'égard de facebook concernant la
désinformation autour du coc vide quel
est votre message aux plateformes comme
facebook ils tuent des gens je veux dire
regardez la seule pandémie que nous
avons et parmi les non vaccinés et tuent
des gens
joe biden est revenu sur ses propos
aujourd'hui en atteignant un petit peu
ces accusations expliquant qu'
évidemment facebook ne tue pas
directement des gens mais que d'une
façon ils sont quelque peu responsable
de ce qu'il se passe du fait que
certains américains ne se vaccinent pas
il faut se dire que facebook avait pas
très pas trop apprécié évidemment les
déclarations du locataire de la maison
blanche
la direction de facebook dit avoir mis
en place énormément de ressources pour
justement lutter contre la
désinformation 167 millions distille de
publication ont été supprimés depuis le
début de la pandémie
écoutez cet extrait du communiqué donc
de facebook en réaction aux propos de
joe biden les données montrent que 85 %
des utilisateurs de facebook aux états
unis ont été ou souhaitent être vaccinés
contre le kobe 19
l'objectif du président by john était de
70 % d'américains vacciner au 4 juillet
facebook n'est pas la raison pour
laquelle cet objectif a été manquée et
thomas la question de l'adhésion des
américains à la vaccination est aussi
source de débat très politique
oui parce que lors de la même conférence
de presse qui a donc lieu la semaine
dernière à la maison blanche la porte
parole james a qui a indiqué que
l'administration de la maison blanche
donc signalait des publications à
facebook ce qui a provoqué une passe
d'armes avec un journaliste de fox news
ce journaliste interrogeant la porte
parole de la maison blanche si c'était
bien le rôle de l'administration byden
en l'occurrence de signaler des
publications à facebook il a fait
référence à big brother évidemment
référence donc au livre 1984 de george
orwell foxnews qui est d'ailleurs est
aussi accusé par certains justement de
proposer de propager une forme
d'hésitation à la vaccination c'est en
tout cas ce que pense anthony fochi vous
savez il est le conseiller santé de la
maison blanche il a été interrogé ce
week-end sur l'antenne de cnn justement
au sujet de la position dont de foxy
nous écouter le docteur anthony fauci
si nous avions eu le rejet des vaccins
que nous voyons dans certains médias je
ne pense pas qu'il aurait été possible
d' éradiquer la variole
nous aurions probablement toujours la
variole et nous aurions probablement
toujours la polio dans ce pays si nous
avions eu le genre de fausses
informations qui sont répondus
actuellement voilà évidemment qu'une
déclaration qui a provoqué beaucoup de
réactions beaucoup de débats politiques
il faut dire qu'un certain nombre d'élus
d'opposition dont des républicains
estiment que c'est plutôt l'attitude et
la stratégie globale de la maison
blanche qui alimente en quelque sorte
l'hésitation de certains américains à la
vaccination et puis dans ce débat il ya
un acteur qui est intervenu c'est
évidemment l'ancien président des états
unis donald trump qui a publié un
communiqué ces dernières heures en
estimant que si les américains ne se
font pas vacciner c'est parce qu'ils ne
font tout simplement pas confiance à
l'administration de joe biden merci
beaucoup thomas bonnin en direct depuis
et washington
pendant bien ce scandale d'espionnage
retentissant la sphère et gazeuse rendu
public par un collectif de 17 médias
internationaux ensemble ils ont enquêté
sur ce logiciel israélien élaboré par
l'entreprise et la sauve groupe
il aurait permis d'espionner plus de
cinquante mille numéros de téléphone
pour le compte d'une dizaine d'états
journalistes politiques et chefs
d'entreprises confondues le maroc
notamment à lui seul le pays est
soupçonné d'avoir ciblé 10 mille numéros
de téléphone ces deux dernières années
une accusation démentie par rabat autre
réaction l'onu qui souhaite une
meilleure régulation des technologies de
surveillance en france une trentaine de
journalistes ont été visés le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriela talent a
réagi ce matin
ces faits sont extrêmement choquant des
faits qui s'ils sont avérés sont
extrêmement graves il va y avoir
évidemment des enquêtes des
éclaircissements demandés
le procès pour corruption de jacob zuma
a repris ce matin en afrique du sud
après plusieurs jours d'émeutes il se
déroule sous haute sécurité
l incarcération de l'ancien président
entraîné la semaine dernière des scènes
de violence et de pillage sans précédent
elles ont fait près de 200 morts des
attaques coordonnées et planifiée selon
l'actuel chef de l'état
cyril ramaphosa précision de polak lier
journalistes pour rire tu es
internationale le procès de l'ancien
président sud africain jacob zuma
reprend aujourd'hui liste lundi
ici dans sa province natale le kwazulu
natal en afrique du sud
certains craignent la reprise des
pillages des violences des troubles de
la semaine dernière d
que l'afrique du sud n'avait plus connu
depuis des décennies jacob zuma est sous
le coup de sept chefs d'accusation pour
fraude corruption et raquettes
il clame son innocence de même que ses
soutiens mais les tribunaux l'ont
déclarée coupable en fin de mois dernier
outrage à la cour et faire incarcérer ce
qui a déclenché la récente vague de
violences dont nous avons été témoins
c'est pourquoi certains redoutent de
nouveaux troubles les violences ont
causé la mort de plus de 200 personnes
et non seulement ici mais dans tout le
pays le président cyril ramaphosa a
déclaré qu'il s'agissait d'une attaque
coordonnée et bien organisée contre le
gouvernement
la situation est certainement semer la
discorde au sein du parti du congrès
national africain
certaines personnes ont suggéré qu'il y
aurait une troisième corse en jeu pour
d'autres il s'agit d'une tentative de
coup d'état
la plupart des personnes avec lesquelles
je me suis entretenu disent que les
violences sont loin d'être terminée et
nous nous attendons aujourd'hui à de
potentiels nouveaux heurts beaucoup sont
d'accord pour dire qu'il s'agit de
criminels et de gens qui n'ont rien
profitant de l'occasion pour piller des
commerces et récupérer autant de
marchandises gratuite caucchioli
l'audience risque de raviver des
tensions c'est pourquoi la police
l'armée et les forces de sécurité
communautaire sont prêtes à l'action au
cours des derniers jours j'ai parcouru
l'afrique du sud à d'urban dans le
kwazulu natal
les gens font la queue pendant des
heures devant les commerces restaient
ouverts pour acheter des denrées de base
calculée du pain de nombreuses boutiques
ont été pillées les autres ont fermé
afin de se protéger
il ya également une pénurie d'argent
liquide edge et que devant les
distributeurs la nuit parfois même le
jour on peut voir des membres de la
communauté armées patrouillant les rues
l'aise notamment les carrefours et des
quartiers marchands afin d'empêcher les
pilleurs d'attendre ces zones
oui en sommes dans l'expectative de
violence
qui pourraient s'exacerber dans le
courant de la journée et je vous
tiendrai informé des événements procès
anti le pen centrafrique
on va revenir à présent sur l' affaire
d'espionnage pegasus avec notre invité
ce soir fabrice epelboin un spécialiste
des réseaux sociaux et enseignant à
sciences po paris
bonsoir fabrice epelboin merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france ce soir alors ce
scandale d'espionnage appelé projet
pegasus on peut parler de violation des
droits de l'homme alors petit problème
technique avec notre invité fabrice
epelboin pour parler de cette affaire
d'espionnage on reviendra peut-être au
cours du jt avec cet invité on va
retourner en france avec ce zoom sur le
combat de la famille triboulet le
morbihan elle refuse de démolir son
habitation construite sur le domaine
public maritime à arradon la loi
littoral l'y oblige les clous l'espère
pouvoir profiter encore quelques temps
de leur propriété après une entrevue
positive est cette semaine avec le
préfet reportage mardi demain c'est
demeure de la fin du 19e siècle situé
dans la commune d'arradon christophe
triboulet la connais très bien depuis
trois générations sa famille est
propriétaire des murs mais pas du
terrain qui appartient à l'état sur 500
mètres carrés de superficie 300 sont une
emprise sur la mer est donc un élément
du domaine public maritime
début juin les tribus les ont reçus une
nouvelle injonction de démolir la maison
familiale de peine et de mer avant le
1er janvier 2022
en france ce cas n'est pas une première
et certains ont réussi à obtenir gain de
cause
pour christophe triboulet la justice
française est à deux vitesses dans les
calanques de marseille des outer ont été
délivrés aux petits du patrimoine et des
outer sont délivrées aussi au titre du
patrimoine sur l'île aux oiseaux dans le
bassin d'arcachon et
et donc effectivement on a deux poids
deux mesures c'est à dire que si vous
êtes corse et si vous êtes marseillais
les choses se passent plus facilement
pour vous le dpm est beaucoup moins
strictes et les a ôté sont donnés pour
plus facilement
on a un état de droit mais mais le droit
s'applique différemment que vous soyez
en corse en paca ou en aquitaine et
encore moins en bretagne tous les cinq
ans la famille de christophe triboulet a
pu bénéficier d'une a ôté une
autorisation d'occupation temporaire du
domaine public
la loi littoral de 1986 a changé la
donne et six ans plus tard un bras de
fer juridique s'est engagée vingt ans
après les triboulet doivent s'incliner
mais en 2011 alors que l'élection
présidentielle approche l'autorisation
d'occupation temporaire est reconduite
pour dix ans une décennie plus tard la
maison doit être finalement détruite
comme ordonné en 1999
une aberration pour certains habitants
et riverains
je pense que c'est dommage qu'elle fasse
pas qu'elle disparaisse parce qu elle l
a toujours fait partie du patrimoine moi
c'est vrai que celui passé de beaucoup
de mes vacances ici étant jeune et j'ai
souffert la maison a toujours été là on
sait qu'on est arrivé à peine hermens
parce qu'on a les tourelles de chez les
tribus les et puis les tourelles du
petit fortin qui est là bas
voilà donc non il faut pas la détruire
c'est loin d'être une verrue dans le
paysage et à il ya certainement autre
chose à faire et je pense que même
plutôt serait plutôt valoriser cette
maison les jeunes il y habite depuis
longtemps c'est leur maison de famille
même si les sommes pas eu permis de
construire mais sa date d digi singer
paquet d'années
l'acte de propriété la maison se situe
sur une ans classé par la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles pour
empêcher sa destruction christophe
triboulet a lancé une pétition qui a
déjà recueilli plus de 40 mille
signatures face à cette mobilisation la
préfecture de vannes a voulu renouer le
dialogue
sollicité par la rédaction de rtl france
elle n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur le
sujet mais la famille triboulet obtenu
quelques avancées
monsieur le préfet
essayez de trouver la solution pour que
ma mère puisse garder cette maison
jusqu'à sa mort c'est à dire qu'à sa
mort la maison ne serait pas démoli et
elle irait
elle retournerait dans les clae
retournerai au préfet et le préfet
donnera les clés soit la mairie
d'arradon soit au conservatoire du
littoral
christophe triboulet souhaitait obtenir
une nouvelle autorisation d'occupation
temporaire sans succès donc mais un
deuxième rendez vous avec le préfet est
prévue au mois d'août à vannes avec
l'espoir pour la famille triboulet de
pouvoir encore jouer quelques années de
leur havre de paix voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à tous de l'avoir
suivi prochain journal dans une
trentaine de minutes c'est bien avec
nous sur arte france à thala
[Musique]
des militaires français dont certains
essaient savait qu'il pouvait y avoir
des conséquences très graves sur la
population et pourtant ils ont mené les
essais nucléaires au moins lors d'un
essai l'essai centaure qui a eu lieu le
17 juillet 1974 l'ensemble de la
population polynésienne a été exposé
bien au delà de ce millisieverts cette
population là ne connaissez absolument
rien du nucléaire dont il a été très
facile pour l'état pendant des années de
nous vendre la thèse des essais par la
ministre de la mémoire et des anciens
combattants geneviève darrieussecq à
elle dit que la france n'avait pas
commis de mensonges d'état qu'est ce
qu'on peut répondre